نعود الآن إلى أخبارنا العاجلة هنا في
الشرق الأوسط، انفجار هائل في
أكبر مخيم للاجئين في غزة، ينضم
إلينا الآن المقدم ريتشارد
هيك، وهو المتحدث الدولي
باسم قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية، شكرًا
جزيلاً لانضمامك إلينا، أريد أن أسألك
أولاً  حول هذا الانفجار الهائل الذي
رأيناه جميعًا للتو، شاهدنا الفيديو في
مخيم جباليا للاجئين في غزة، هل هناك
أي شيء آخر يمكنك أن
تخبرنا به أولاً عن كيفية حدوث هذا الانفجار،
وسأشكرك على استضافتي لذلك
سنخرج
نأمل في الساعة القادمة بمزيد من البيانات ولكن يمكنني
تحديثك الآن أنه كان هناك
قائد كبير جدًا من حماس في تلك المنطقة
للأسف كان يختبئ مرة أخرى كما يفعلون
خلف أه داخل المدنيين وهذا
كل ما يمكنني رؤيته في هذه المرحلة التي
نبحث فيها  سنخرج
بمزيد من البيانات عندما نعرف ما حدث
هناك، فهل يمكنك تأكيد أنه كان
هجومًا إسرائيليًا أدى إلى تدمير
صندوق كبير من مخيم جباليا للاجئين
نعم
يمكنني أن نذهب، لقد ركزنا على استهداف
قائد كبير  وولف وسوف نقوم
بتزويدك بمزيد من البيانات مع
مرور الساعة
ولكن حتى لو كان قائد حماس هذا
موجودًا وسط كل هؤلاء
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الموجودين في
مخيم جبالا للاجئين فإن إسرائيل ما زالت تتقدم
وأسقطت قنبلة هناك في محاولة
لقتل حماس أه كاماس
قائد حماس هذا مع العلم أن الكثير من
المدنيين الأبرياء رجالاً ونساءً وأطفالاً من
المفترض أن يُقتلوا هو أن ما
أسمعه هذا ليس ما تسمعه
جيدًا إذا ركزنا مرة أخرى على هذا
القائد مرة أخرى من أنت  سنحصل على المزيد من البيانات حول هوية
هذا الرجل الذي قتل العديد من
الإسرائيليين. نحن نبذل كل ما في وسعنا، فهي
ساحة معركة معقدة للغاية، وقد تكون هناك بنية تحتية
هناك، وقد تكون هناك أنفاق،
وما زلنا نبحث في الأمر وسنقوم بذلك  أعطيك
المزيد من البيانات مع
مرور الساعة ولكنك تعلم أن هناك الكثير
من اللاجئين والعديد من المدنيين الأبرياء من الرجال
والنساء والأطفال في
مخيم اللاجئين هذا أيضًا،
هذه هي مأساة حرب الذئب،
أعني أننا كما تعلمون "  لقد كنت أرى
منذ أيام تحركًا جنوبًا إلى الشرير غير
متورط مع حماس، يرجى التحرك جنوبًا،
نعم، أحاول فقط الحصول على
مزيد من المعلومات، كنت تعلم أن هناك
مدنيين هناك، وكنت تعلم أن هناك
لاجئين من جميع أنواع اللاجئين ولكنك
قررت الاستمرار  أسقط قنبلة على
مخيم اللاجئين هذا محاولًا قتل
قائد سما بالمناسبة، هل
قُتل، لا أستطيع التأكيد بعد، سيكون هناك
المزيد من التحديثات، نعم، نحن نعلم أنه
قُتل أم بخصوص المدنيين هناك، فنحن
نفعل كل ما نقوم به  يمكنني
التقليل من ذلك، سأقولها، سأقولها
مرة أخرى للأسف، إنهم يختبئون
بين السكان المدنيين ومرة ​​أخرى نحن
نقوم بهذه الخطوة مرحلة تلو الأخرى
وسنلاحق كل واحد من هؤلاء
الإرهابيين الذين شاركوا في ذلك
هجوم هيوس على 7 أكتوبر
وولف